[Musik]
zum politischen tagesgespräch begrüßt
sich heute jungen leuten den
vorstandssprecher der afg guten tag
erneuten guten morgen erstmal vielen
dank dass sie im regen war gewartet
haben sie müssen ein bisschen warten
wegen der ereignisse in österreich ja
eine sicht des terrors schreibt jetzt
die kanzlerin wird deutschen stehen in
anteilnahme und solidarität an der seite
unserer österreichischen freunde der
islamistische terror ist unser
gemeinsamer feind der kampf gegen diese
mörder und ihre anstifter ist unser
gemeinsamer kampf
wir wollten das sagt die kanzlerin was
sagen sie zu den ereignissen von wien
gestern abend ja zunächst einmal sind
die worte der kanzlerin hier angemessen
als erste ist ganz sicherlich die
anteilnahme vier völlig unschuldige
menschen die am abend vor dem lok tor
noch mal ausgehen wollten sind nun tot
wir haben etliche verletzte und das
erste ist die anteilnahme auszusprechen
gegenüber diesen menschen und ihren
angehörigen
das ist fürchterlich aber es darf
natürlich in der politik in der wir uns
befinden nicht mit anteilnahme und
gemeinsamer trauer allein getan sein
wir müssen uns sehr entschieden die
frage stellen wie soll das weitergehen
diese anschläge kommen in immer kürzerer
folge die einschläge kommen immer näher
wir haben das jetzt in gestern in wien
wir hatten vor wenigen tagen in nizza
die grauenhaften ereignis wir hatten die
enthauptung samuel partie in frankreich
und wir sehen dass wir eine
islamistische gefährdungslage haben die
wirklich hochgradig gravierend ist die
unsere demokratie und unsere freiheit
gefährdet und hier ist jetzt ganz
entschieden die wehrhafte demokratie
gefordert wir müssen sehen dass wir
dieser menschen habhaft werden und dass
wir diese menschen auch aus unserem
freiheitlichen europa entfernen und da
war schnell das als erste reaktion auf
diesen fürchterlichen islamistischen
anschlag gestern in wien
herr morgen jetzt zum großen thema
corona gestern ist ja dieser teil
lockdown in deutschland in kraft
getreten
die kanzlerin hat sich gestern in der
bundespressekonferenz dazu noch einmal
ausführlich
äußert was tragen sie als afc mit und
was nicht was wir mit tragen sind die
verbote von großveranstaltungen und alle
maßnahmen wo menschen eben zwangsläufig
sehr sehr eng zusammen kommen körperlich
zusammenkommen das hat sicherlich in
dieser zeit kein platz und da muss man
agieren
wir tragen ganz entschieden nicht mit
den aktionismus sind die bundesregierung
an den tag legt wir haben hier in
wirklichen aktionismus stadt strategie
dass wir nicht mittragen definitiv nicht
mittragen ist die schließung von
hotellerie und gaststätten auch von
kulturstätten wenn sie sich anschauen
was diese menschen getan haben
gerade in der gastronomie wo ich das
ganz viel auch mitbekommen
um den anforderungen dieser dieser
herausforderung gerecht zu werden
und nun werden sie mit einem weiteren
lockdown bestraft wurde das
infektionsgeschehen nachweislich da
haben wir klare empirie dort gar nicht
stattfindet dann ist das ein blinder
aktionismus und den tragen wir nicht mit
ich habe stark den eindruck dass die
regierung hier im nebel stochert selbst
wenn jetzt die infektionszahlen
daraufhin runter gehen sollten und wir
sind uns ja alle dessen keineswegs
sicher wie soll das weitergehen wir
beenden den lock down und dann geht es
wieder hoch und machen den dritten
vierten fünften lockdown das kann es
auch so nicht sein sondern wir müssen
hier viel spezifischer agieren und die
afg hat dazu andere vorstellungen
ja wahrscheinlich wissen dass die
handelnden noch gerne erläutern
wahrscheinlich wissen dass die
handelnden politiker ja auch nicht wie
es weitergeht im dezember in dem januar
und soweit es ist ja auch ihre erste
pandemie haben heute was man aber weiß
ist wie die zahlen von heute aus in
15.000 neue erkrankungen sie wissen ja
auch wie es in europa aussieht gerade
auch brüssel ist ja völlig still gelegt
weil die zahlen dort so hoch sind das
wäre doch für die afg für die afg ist
eine gute situation patriotismus zu
beweisen die kanzlerin hat ja gestern
solidarität mit den schwachen in dieser
gesellschaft eingefordert wie wäre es
denn wenn die afd sich mal an die seite
der schwachen stellen würde in dieser
situation
anstatt von corona diktatur und
ähnlichen dingen zu reden
aber mit verlaub genau das tun wir
stellen uns an die seite derer die hart
von maßnahmen getroffen werden die gar
nicht ergriffen werden müssten
und wir sagen ja ausdrücklich nicht dass
nichts getan werden müsste ist auch
völlig unbestreitbar dass wir eine
dynamik des infektionsgeschehen nach
geschehens haben dass sie hochgefährlich
ist und dass wir darauf reagieren müssen
nur muss man dann eben tatsächlich
angemessen und mit maß und mitte agieren
und dazu würde würden andere maßnahmen
gehören als die die bundesregierung
ergreift wir sind zum beispiel der
auffassung dass man viel viel stärker
auf schnelltests zu setzen sollte die
sind mittlerweile von einer sehr hohen
spezifizität da kommen wir bei gesunden
bei auf 99,7 prozent bei erkrankten auf
immerhin 96 5 prozent haben wir ganz
klare daten und was uns fehlt ist eine
klare datenlage mir kommt das vor wie
eine jagdgesellschaft die auf einer
völligen dunkelheit in einer lichtung
auf ein den einen fuchs schießt aber
nicht sieht und damit strohfeuer agiert
das hat so keinen sinn man muss dann
wirklich zielgerichtet agieren und dazu
brauchen wir informationen wir brauchen
daten
die können die schnelltests liefern da
wäre geld gut angelegt wir müssen
massenweise schnelltests zu haben und
zwar antigen test und antikörper test
weil die deutlich besser sind als die
pcr test auf diese art und weise kann
man viel zielgerichteter handeln und
muss nicht ein ganzes land in lockdown
schicken naja sind die menschen massiv
betroffen und wenn herr scholz wenn herr
scholz sagt mit verlaub das würde alles
bezahlt werden ja von wem wird das von
herrn scholz gezeigt wird das von frau
merkel bezahlt das ist das geld der
steuerzahler
und es funktioniert so nicht und die
menschen wollen arbeiten und sie können
auch arbeiten ohne dass man damit die
dynamische infektionsgeschehen zweiter
problematisieren also soviel zu diesen
forderungen in sachen corona pandemie
und schnelltests ermorden
als zum schluss noch es soll ja ein
parteitag stattfinden der afg ein
bundesparteitag in vier wochen in kalkar
in nordrhein westfalen haben niederrhein
wie sieht es damit aus die anderen
parteien haben jahre ihre partei tage
unisono abgesagt jedenfalls zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt sieht es so aus als wenn sie
nicht durchgeführt werden können sie
wollen aber weiterhin tagen ist das
nicht viel zu gefährlich
in der jetzigen lage wenn man sich
verantwortungsbewusst verhält wenn man
alle hygiene standards einhält wenn man
die abstandsregeln ein held wenn man
masken trägt bei begegnung dann ist das
aus unserer sicht verantwortbar es wird
letztlich den geschichte sein die
wahrscheinlich juristisch entschieden
wird es gibt eine klare zuordnung des
landes nordrhein-westfalen und über die
wird sich herausstellen ob für den
parteitag werden abhalten können oder
nicht wenn wir ihn abhalten können was
wir uns wünschen würden denn man macht
das nicht aus jux und dollerei sondern
aus politischer verantwortung
dann wird das nach all jene standards
die es nur gibt stattfinden damit es
dort keine keine infektionen gibt das
ist doch ganz selbstverständlich jj main
der vorstandssprecher der afg erneuten
vielen dank für ihre zeit an diesem
morgen und einen schönen tag noch
nach herrn in baden württemberg wünsche
ich ihnen auch vielen dank guten tag